(female announcer)
When a woman has to find a shirt
for her special guy,
what will it take for him
to say "Fine" to the shirt?
If you love
"Say Yes to the Dress,"
you'll understand the concept
of our show,
"Say Fine To The Shirt"!
Amy and her fiancé Brian are
shopping for a replacement shirt
after he left his main shirt
at an airport.
Just pick something,
let's go.
Hi!
♪♪
Welcome, how are you?
You look great.
Thank you.
And you must be?
Brian.
Didn't catch it.
(slurred) Brian!
Nice to meet you "Rah."
No, he's saying "Brian."
Brian, Brian.
Nice to meet you, Brian.
Jeez, I just
said it 14 times.
He's so cute.
Didn't catch that either.
So you're our man and
let's find you a shirt!
(Amy)
Brian and I have been together
for five years,
and engaged
for four-and-a-half years.
Brian is... my soul mate.
We met and we both knew
right away,
so I asked him to marry me,
and he said,
and I'll never forget it,
he said,
"Fine, I guess."
So, guys, what's our
price range today?
Um, I would say anything
between $50, up to--
If it's like, amazing,
like, 12,000? Um...
I don't know,
what do you think, babe?
Like, what are you
comfortable with?
(muttering indistinctly)
Okay, great.
Are we thinking
sexy, classic sleeves?
Maybe some buttons?
Oh! Buttons!
Yeah?
Did you say buttons?
Yeah, buttons.
Did you hear her?
Buttons?
Are you listening?
Brian?
Are you even listening?
What?
Why am I here?
I have another shirt.
I don't need "another"
another shirt.
Okay, Brian, when
you were a little boy
and every night,
you dreamed about clothing,
what shirt
did you see?
That never happened.
I didn't dream about
stupid stuff like that.
Seriously, though,
I gotta piss.
Is this fine?
Yeah.
Fine.
Well, it seems like Brian
will wear almost anything,
so it's really gonna
take all my skills
to make this prince
feel like a princess.
Oh!
Oh, my God!
What do you think?
Brian has not seen Josh
and Beaver since college,
so I hired a private detective
to track them down.
It cost me $20,000,
but it is so
gonna be worth it
to see the look on Brian's
face when he sees them.
Open.
I got your two
best friends from college
to come to share
in our joy.
Yo, what up?
Hey, man.
You hear T.J. died?
Oh, for real?
What's up, Beav?
Yo.
(whispering)
Magical.
(Travis)
Hey, gang!
So Brian, this is
a Tommy Bahama.
Okay, so it is blue,
it has buttons.
What do you think?
Whatever.
Fantastic.
Let's try it on.
Come on.
(sighing)
Come on, come on.
(whispering)
Buttons.
(announcer)
It's time
for the big reveal.
Brian has just tried on
the shirt.
Will it be fine or will it be
back to the rack for Travis?
Okay, let's see
our prince!
(gasping)
He looks amaze.
Friends, thoughts?
Pretty cool.
Doesn't look too gay.
Okay, and you, Brian,
what do you think?
Is it everything
you were hoping for?
I guess.
(Travis)
You know what?
I think we need
to jack him up.
What?
Stand over there.
Do it.
What?
Let him jack
you up, guy!
Just trust me,
just trust me.
Now, look.
I don't wanna look.
Look in the mirror.
Yes! This is
my new main shirt.
Brian, are you saying
"fine" to the shirt?
Fine.
Oh!
Fine, yes!
A thousand times fine!
(Brian)
I love it!
This has been such
a hard year for me.
I just never felt
that good about myself
and then I just looked at myself
in the mirror
and I'm like...
I felt like a butterfly.
You know, at the end
of the day,
my real job is
to make dreams come true.
Also, I'm a cashier
at Petco.
♪♪